لديها الكثير لتقدمه، متاحفها،
قصر مورابا في ريا، كانت ريا مجرد
قرية صغيرة على حافة الصحراء
ذهبت في أحد عطلات نهاية الأسبوع لقضاء
نزهة [موسيقى]
ما جذبني إلى العالم العربي
والسياحة كان بمثابة  نتيجة رحلاتي
حول العالم عام 1987، كانت
المرة الأولى التي أزور فيها دولًا مثل إيران،
زرت أفغانستان دول
الأردن وسوريا في تلك الأيام على الرغم من أن المملكة العربية
السعودية لم تكن مطروحة على الورق لأنه لم يكن
بإمكانك زيارة البلد، لم يكن كذلك
مستحيل إلا إذا كنت تعيش وتعمل
هناك من حيث الأماكن التي كنا
سنزورها في المملكة العربية السعودية، أعني أننا
نغطي البلد، وسأبدأ دائمًا
في الرياض لأن هذه هي العاصمة التي
سنذهب إليها إلى BEDA وH وخاصة
جبة الجندل في  شمال
البلاد آل جو مذهل
وخاصة الرجيل الحجارة
الدائمة هذه الحجارة الدائمة مذهلة أعني
أنها أقدم من
ستونهنج، كانت اللقاءات مع
البدو دائمًا مميزة جدًا لأنها
كانت مختلفة جدًا عن سكان المدن
أو كما يمكن القول  الشعب السعودي بشكل
عام لأنه كان لديهم
قواعد سلوك مختلفة وأيضًا من
وقت لآخر عندما يقول أحد أفراد عائلة صديق عزيز رو أوه من
فضلك، أريد
مقابلتهم، سأقوم بالترفيه عنهم،
سأضع  غداء لهم
ويأتون إلى حديقتي ويأتون إلى منزلي
الذي كان أيضًا مميزًا جدًا
ولطيفًا جدًا، لذلك فيما يتعلق بإدارة هذه
الرحلات الاستكشافية الصحراوية، كان عالم الرجال
في تلك الأيام وكنت تتعامل مع
الرجال سواء كان ذلك عند نقطة تفتيش
سواء كان الأمر يتعلق بالحصول على الأذونات
المطلوبة ولكن دائمًا الاحترام
من كل جهة وفي كثير من النواحي
كنت مثل الارتقاء إلى مرتبة
الرجل،
فمن المثير للاهتمام رؤية أنواع أه
النمو في بعض الأحيان لدي
مشاعر مختلطة ولكن لا يمكنك إيقاف التقدم  كما
تعلمون فإن التقدم موجود في كل مكان في
العالم، وبينما قد أشتاق إلى بعض
الماضي في نفس الوقت، فإن ما تم
إنجازه يتم بحساسية وهو من
أجل مستقبل الشعب
ومستقبل الشعب السعودي
[موسيقى]
الجزيرة العربية